welcome to this video I'm playing
Westphalia from Germany let's see maybe
it's a living not far away from me after
all we are always always invest filia
well if ok let's see again the age 3
line
the 97 okay is going 4-4 be known him
but this is not a very good form of that
in with a night on g7 already you're not
really even getting in a six-year under
favorable circumstances or need to
prepare this and in some way without e6
and the e-file open it's really not a
good good a good setup
yeah okay here i will not take but
initiate the typical play on that on the
kingside g4 being directed against their
five month sorry okay i want to make
sure that is not completely closing down
the coincide with a five
interesting maybe Bishop f6 g5 is this
idea possible in this case I will just
return to our three with the night no
problem just covering g5 and I can still
play mh4 and further advances group g1
for example yeah I thought I can just
play em I just can just capture I have
h4 h4 takes g5 Fisk at age three okay
g5 h3 and still a very good position
check now just I can also just play I go
this first h1
yeah this is this is probably the best
one I hope f6 and no H for he cannot
take rearick takes check and Bishop g7
advanced Edwin's instantly I think at
least I'm breaking through and yeah I'm
threatening to take on g5 I mean look so
very problematic
Jeff yeah this should be to wear looks
looks okay so yeah how to best play that
the Ceph form possible or taking Queenie
to and then just sacrificing whatever I
do I will need them I will need the
second rope here okay I i really cannot
care about the a5 pawn anymore so if you
want you can take that but i cannot
believe this is possible so idea is
Bishop b5 95 Queenie to and sacrifice
them or maybe f4 it's also not bad f4
intending f5 and is also strong actually
f4 if he takes Bishop takes it's very
nice opening up form for my bishops
very tough to defend okay he decided to
take it yeah probably just open just
capture this and now we even grabs this
amazing okay so f for the check I can
just go to see to where there is nothing
bad happening to me yeah I'm just
attacking the 6 cm
and then let's say we should be six
Queen g5 those kind of ideas um a young
before I have not be one right
okay I cannot sacrifice here I think but
Queen g5 isn't this good I will check
simply can we can take what the rook
hmm not not seeing a clear win him
yeah but I must I must move simply I
cannot spend even more time here I think
rookie to as as possible here the sum at
least keeps black going for the moment
rookie 292 queen a1 check-rein maybe i'm
just i'm just still winning but wow it's
as it gets messy okay i have night f1
ig3 chess only check i go to be back if
he takes he i have 93 this is covering E
4 enter taking the bishop here
timeline is still 93 I can take here
this is a double chicken made dumb
Knight f6 is double double check and
made checkmate exactly this but i think
it was winning now right i can i can
take on h5 next yeah yeah I can take on
d1 but I'm still left with the huge plus
yeah okay it is this video should be
should be a winning position f3 is also
possible but this looked maybe f3 is
really better what the computer is
recommending here I mean it's plus 4
plus 4 is quite a lot in term check this
this is also should be winning maybe
maybe I'm playing this wrong I mean f4
immediately is maybe even stronger just
opening this up okay Matt well the
computers always giving me plus 4 here
it just feels a bit scary for the human
storm I mean it looks totally winning
but I have lost my fair share of games
in the Kings Indian Giants always + 7 +
8 okay I was so always a bit skeptical
that something bad might happen this is
the relatively best defense check check
but ok I'm ruining the house iam yeah
it's just not not a very good opening
line even here i would say that black is
already in now somewhat bad shape until
this is a very nice version of all this
maybe I should even play Queen d2 first
and get the
into h 7 but ok this is just good black
is not getting in there five under any
any circumstance and white just has a
big space advantage on both flanks ok
thanks for watching